george before we let you go the one
thing that i want to talk about with
bitcoin is uh in one of your recent
videos you talked about bitcoin uh
potentially being purchased by the
federal reserve or the u.s government uh
we've obviously seen el salvador go
ahead and kind of plug into the network
right they've set up a bunch of atms uh
they've created a fund they're handing
bitcoin to people who sign up for their
bitcoin wallet that they've created uh
and they seem to really kind of be
pushing it forward in a way that no
other nation state has done what are
your thoughts in terms of the us
government's relationship with bitcoin
should they buy it will they buy it how
do you think about it
very difficult you know are we saying
that bitcoin is still a digital kind of
uh
asset or like a reserve asset store
value or is it uh is it money is it
competing with the dollar because then i
think the the fed or the the central
planners do different things
also is the stock market crashing and or
is uh have we gotten to a point in the
united states where the economy is so
dependent upon
cryptocurrency or maybe asset prices in
general and a good portion of that would
be crypto i'm thinking three years down
the road as an example you know would
they need to step in and actually buy
that
buy stocks would they need to step in i
mean they're already buying mortgages
obviously to prop up that market but
would they need to buy cryptocurrency to
prop up those markets
so there there wasn't a decrease in
aggregate demand because they're all
keynesians at the end of the day so
that's their nightmares that aggregate
demand somehow goes down and if that's
the only way to maintain aggregate
demand
that may incentivize them to do that now
as far as taking it onto their balance
sheet
um as a reserve asset
potentially but but i don't think they
would if bitcoin is uh competing against
the dollar directly in their eyes
in their eyes
uh i think they may be incentivized and
especially other central banks may be
incentivized to do that if they continue
to see uh
bitcoin exclusively as just a digital
reserve asset so without opening a can
of worms uh two of the countries that i
could easily see uh being very
interested who have publicly stated
they'd like to get off the dollar system
uh but who have ultimately failed to do
it up until now is russia and china uh
do you think that it's more likely that
maybe uh a competitor to america uh
would do it or do you think it's more
likely that the us like like i'm very
fascinated by this idea of like the
global game theory and when somebody
like el salvador with six and a half
million people does it i think there's
some people who say oh like that that's
an inflection point that that's
interesting there's a lot of other
people who just say hey they got six and
a half million people there's kind of
consolidated power uh you essentially
have a president and his brothers who
are younger they're forward thinking
from a technology perspective and so you
know it kind of makes sense
it's very different if the rumors around
brazil potentially doing something we've
seen some legislation uh
kind of presented or if the united
states was to do it or russia or china
and some of these like large large
countries with hundreds of millions of
people
so how do you just think about uh you
know i guess like the the competition
among the super powers the people who
actually have very large citizen bases
and frankly have just large economies
that uh this isn't such a simple uh
decision it's just like hey we're gonna
buy somewhere to get 30 everyone who
downloads the wallet and if we screw it
up well we're dollarized country and it
may not be as uh kind of uh big of an
issue given that we wouldn't really be
risking our own currency like how do you
think about that
well if you've got a brazil and so
you're talking about the central bank
taking it onto their balance sheet
uh just simply as a reserve asset like
they would gold or something like that
is that what you're referring to yeah i
think and again some of this is just
like we don't know exactly what they're
doing but it if you look at like russia
russia has openly said hey they're going
to be a net seller uh of dollars for
sure they want to get rid of their
dollar assets uh in some cases i think
it was maybe a year or two ago central
banks around the world were net sellers
of gold for one quarter so not kind of a
persistent thing but but they basically
for the first time in a long time have
become a net seller and so you start to
think about okay that would lead me to
believe that they're at least evaluating
what are the assets that are in the
reserves and then what are the assets
that we could potentially move to and
there's some reallocation that goes on
uh it feels like you know there's some
threshold i don't think it's at a
trillion dollars but is it at five
trillion dollar market cap 10 trillion
20 trillion you know where's that
threshold where eventually bitcoin
becomes so big and it does have enough
of a track record where one of the large
central banks says hey we're not going
to use this as a medium of exchange or a
threat to our kind of reserve currency
of our economy but we are going to use
it as a reserve asset in our central
bank just like we would gold or anything
else
i think it's interesting especially if
the country had a tendency to be short
dollars like in argentina right so
you i think there's a good argument why
they would buy bitcoin and keep it on
their balance sheet so the price of
bitcoin goes to let's say five hundred
thousand dollars
uh now all of a sudden they can sell
that reserve asset and get a lot of
dollars that they wouldn't otherwise
have access to and infuse that into the
commercial banking system
to
kind of paper over
any
dollar shortfalls they had because of
the amount of debt that's denominated in
dollars outside of the united states so
let me give you a specific example uh i
don't know if you guys saw the news last
week but china issued 4 billion in bonds
denominated in dollars
right so you got to think okay why the
hell are they doing that i actually had
this conversation with brent johnson uh
we had dinner in new orleans and we were
talking about this
and you you look at evergrand and you
look at fantasia or these other real
estate companies they have a lot of
denominated debt
and so if they don't have the dollar
cash flow coming in to service that debt
which it seems like they do not then
what what is their option well they'll
most likely have to roll the debt over
well that would mean going back to the
bank and saying hey we need another loan
to pay off this loan that is that is
coming due
well if the
the chinese bank doesn't have the
dollars and i i don't i want to say this
carefully because i'm not implying that
they would actually lend
the the dollars to
evergrand because a bank loan creates
new dollars or money fiat currency that
did not exist before but they would need
some sort of dollar denominated asset to
transfer to the other bank if they had
to transfer the liability that they had
just created as a loan to ever grand in
the first place and i know that gets
really confusing but the bottom line
there is if if these banks didn't have
those dollars as reserve assets then
they wouldn't be able to issue and
extend more loans
in a fractional reserve type of way you
know lever up and therefore those
corporations wouldn't have access to the
dollar liquidity they needed
right so
the dollars you know at the end of the
day
although they're slowly declining as far
as percentage of world trade they still
equal like 50 or 60 percent
of
transactions
and uh
and really how they're um
how they're settled so i think if you're
an argentina going back to that example
if you had uh bitcoin and it went up to
100 or 200 or 500 and then you've got
access to so many more dollars that you
didn't have before that could bail out
your corporations or bail out your banks
that had taken on way way way too much
dollars
debt and they didn't have the cash flows
to service it